the year is 1981 the Cold War is in full
swing and the most powerful people in
the world are of course mess and then in
1982 a woman emerges from the shadow of
her celebrity husband to inspire a
generation and become a feminist icon
that woman is miss pac-man miss pac-man
quickly overtook her husband to become
the best-selling game in the world
featuring a strong female protagonist
unafraid to eat constantly kick ass and
look good she sported a flashy red bow
sexy red lipstick and alluring cheek
mole and most significantly a single eye
while the blind pac-man operated by
instinct or perhaps some kind of
echolocation miss pac-man had vision a
vision of gender equality and with four
new mazes different side exits and
faster gameplay miss pac-man knew that
nothing would be handed to her she knew
she would have to work even harder to
earn what pac-man achieved with relative
ease and earn it she did put it this way
in pac-man the ubiquitous rewards like
the Apple cherry and strawberry just sat
there passively for pac-man to stroll up
and take but in MS pac-man the treats
actually move around and evade her ever
subtly subversive miss pac-man was
preparing a new generation of women for
the stark realities of the
male-dominated corporate workforce and
since every Gloria Steinem needs her
Elisabeth Hasselbeck affirmative action
was applied even to the underworld as
inky blinky pinky and Clyde became inky
blinky pinky and sue miss pac-man is
also a socially conscious Crusader and
in 2000 was named the official
spokesperson for the National Alliance
of breast cancer organizations critics
of miss pac-man have branded her a
sellout for not being named pack woman
which is insane
all right because first of all pac-man
is not an English word pac-man is just
the Ellis Island version of his real
Japanese name Pokemon so just having the
name pac-man doesn't if so fact I'll
make you masculine any more than having
the name pokemons makes you Jamaican oh
and second of all miss Backman doesn't
even meet her husband until the end of
act 1 after the second man and when she
does get married she doesn't suddenly
become mrs. pack
man does she know she says ms Backman
which means she keeps her own name
[ __ ]
so for all this and more we salute you
miss pac-man and we hope you kicked the
holy stead of breast cancer because
breast cancer sucks
[Music]